أعتقد أن أحد الأشياء الرئيسية هو أن
الكثير من الجمهور الإسرائيلي قد
تحول تدريجياً من الإيمان
بحل الدولتين
إلى الإيمان الضمني على الأقل
بحل الطبقات الثلاث بأن لديك
دولة واحدة فقط بين نهر الأردن
و  البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​مع ثلاث
فئات من الناس يعيشون هناك يهود
لديهم كل الحقوق بعض العرب لديهم
بعض الحقوق وعرب آخرين لديهم
القليل جدًا أو ليس لديهم
حقوق وهذا هو الوضع بشكل متزايد
على
الأرض وهذا أيضًا هو التطلع بشكل متزايد
أه أو ال  عقلية حتى الأشخاص في
الحكومة
وهذا أمر مقلق للغاية ،
لكن هذا ما يحدث ،
واو لم أسمع صوتك أبدًا ،
لذا فأنت حتى تعتقد أن تغير
المناخ يمكن تخفيفه ، وهذا
أيضًا يعود إلى قضية
التحفيز
لا يعني ذلك أن النزاع قد وصل إلى
نقطة يكون فيها هذا هو الحل الوحيد
الممكن ،
بل لقد وصلنا إلى نقطة يكون فيها هذا هو
الحل المفضل أو الموقف المفضل بالنسبة
r على الأقل بعض
الجمهور الإسرائيلي وكذلك بعض
الحكومة الإسرائيلية لأعضاء الحكومة المستقبليين ،
هذا ليس حتميًا لأنه
لم يكتب في النجوم أو في أي مكان
آخر ، إنه خيار إنساني
، آمل أن يتخذ الناس
خيارات
مختلفة ولكن هذا كل
شيء  يجب علينا أولاً وقبل كل شيء أن
نعترف بما هو الواقع قبل
أن نفكر في طرق لتحسينه ، لذا
أتساءل عما إذا كان ذلك يقودني إلى كتابك الجديد
، أعني أنني أمتلكه هنا ، إنه
كتاب رائع لا نراه عادةً
كتب مثل العاقل والآخرين مع
هذا النوع من الغلاف الطفولي
وبالطبع خلفك لديك صورة أه
من الكتاب لذا فإن
السؤال ويسمى أم أنت تعرف.
للشباب
في ضوء ما كنا نتحدث
عنه للتو عن التحفيز وفهم
ما تعتقد أن
إخبار الأطفال سيفعلونه لتشكيل المستقبل
الذي أفكر فيه على المدى الطويل ، هذا هو
المفتاح
لأن h  كيف ينظر الأطفال إلى العالم هذه هي
الطريقة التي ينظرون بها إلى العالم فيما بعد
كبالغين ، يمكنك تغيير رأيك بعد ذلك ،
لكن من الصعب جدًا أن تتجاهل
ما تعلمته عندما كنت شابًا
إذا نشأت معتقدًا أن أفرادك على
سبيل المثال متفوقون على
الآخرين  شخص أو متفوق على
أي شخص آخر ، وهذا ما تم إطعامه
لسنوات عديدة ، ومن
الصعب جدًا تغيير ذلك
ولسوء الحظ نراه مرة أخرى إنها ليست
ظاهرة إسرائيلية نعيشها في العديد من
البلدان حول العالم في
العديد من الدول حول العالم
العالم يربون شبابهم
على هذا النوع من النظرة القائلة بأننا أفضل
من أي شخص آخر ، فمصالحنا
أكثر أهمية من اهتمامات
أي شخص آخر
،
ولسوء الحظ ،
يؤدي هذا اليوم إلى أزمة وجودية
للبشرية لأن هذا النوع
من التفكير بالطبع لآلاف  من
السنين أدت إلى الحروب والاضطهاد
وما إلى ذلك ولكننا الآن نواجه بعض
المشاكل العالمية الوجودية مثل تغير
المناخ مثل  ظهور
الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي لا يمكن حله
ما لم تتعاون مع
أشخاص آخرين في العالم وإذا كان لدى الناس
هذه العقلية بأننا متفوقون على
الجميع وأن اهتماماتنا فقط هي المهمة ،
فإن التعاون يكاد
يكون مستحيلًا